see far is unique stimulating is
energizing it's a catalyst for discovery
interdisciplinary environment where
people have true conversations I can
point directly to the most important
discoveries in my in my research to
collaborations that have been fostered
by sea far we bring the best Canadian
researchers together with researchers
from around the globe to really move the
dial on things that are important to
mankind going forward questions that the
answers to which will change the world
will change the way we see the world the
way we adapt to the world the way we
understand the world for us the biggest
dream is improving the human condition
if we can do that then I feel we've made
some lasting contribution oh let's
listen because we're learning something
here the goal being curing disease
improving education policy major
technological revolution healthier human
beings levitating drains curing mental
illness shift the paradigm and economic
thinking greener modes of energy to
choose key social outcomes revolutionary
tools for science for business saving
our planet simple enough I think sefa is
really a unique institution and proud of
be Canadian because see far thrives in
my country at sea far researchers can do
what they had always hoped to do they
can dream to see them in action gives me
great hope for for the future of this
country and the world
you